[Musique]
aucune route ne relie l’amérique du Sud
à l'Amérique centrale c'est ainsi qu'on
entre au Panama
après avoir parcouru tes dizaines de
kilomètres à pied dans la jungle du
derrière
[Musique]
ils sont épuisés et soulagés d'avoir
survécu à ce qui est considéré comme
l'une des routes migratoires les plus
dangereuses au monde une centaine de
kilomètres dans une jungle dense et
humide
que je sois en ville en cette femme
elle parle de montagne de section très
épique où il faut s'accrocher aux
racines
se sont connus en chemin se sont entrés
pour survivre la passade
beaucoup affirme avoir croisé plusieurs
cadavres une marche forcée dans un
territoire infesté de gangs criminels
ici les agents frontaliers du Panama
font la loi les conditions sont
précaires mais c'est mieux que la veille
[Musique]
depuis quelques semaines peut-être en
raison des récentes mesures américaines
ou parce que les pluies sont de retour
peu importe ils sont des centaines à
censés chaque jour sur le chemin des
désespérés ce qui souhaitent améliorer
leur sort ou celui des petits qu'il
traîne avec eux non c'est elle prévoit
international lorsque personne
il y a plusieurs chemins qui traversent
le darrians ceux qui ont plus d'argent
ont accès à des chemins plus courts
peut-être on l'imagine aussi moins
pénible ces gens-là arrivent ici dans le
camp de San Vicente qui est géré par le
gouvernement du Panama on retrouve des
gens d’amérique latine bien sûr mais
aussi qui viennent de plus loin
d'Afrique et d'Asie imaginé l'Inde
l'Irak l'Afghanistan et même la Chine
la plupart ne veulent pas parler de leur
expérience peut être à cause du régime
au pouvoir dans le pays qu'ils ont fui
dans la dernière année le nombre de
migrants venus d'Asie a Bondy ici les
adultes reprennent contact avec leurs
proches les enfants retrouvent un peu de
leur innocent voilà
sont passés par 6 pays avant d'arriver
ici il leur a fallu environ 3000 dollars
américains chacun pour fuir les talibans
ils ont les moyens qu'ils partent
quelques heures seulement après être
entré au camp
[Musique]
peu importe l'origine c'est surtout aux
États-Unis qu'ils veulent aller
peut-être au Canada
cette famille n'a plus un sous une
personne pour l'aider et la passer plus
d'une semaine dans ce cas
la jeune mère se sent enfermé mais pas
question d'aller se plaindre
parce que
même si les mesures de contrôle viennent
d'être renforcées dans la région les
États-Unis conseil et renseignent les
autorités du Panama et de la Colombie
ici les migrants ont moins de marge de
manœuvre et la chasse au passeur est
ouverte
mais les raisons de fuir n'ont pas
changé ni le désir d'améliorer son sort
ce qui échoue dans ce camp il passe
souvent plusieurs jours ils ont si peu
pour survivre
[Musique]
sont encore loin de tout
facile dont elle rêve pour ses enfants
en attendant ils sont coincés dans un
camp bondé ils ont trois repas par jour
reçoivent savon et brosse à dents mais
l'eau donnerait la diarrhée les services
médicaux se réminimaux c'est le prix à
payer sans même savoir si le rêve
américain pourra se réaliser
[Musique]
le voyage ne fait que commencer mais
pour bien des gens il y a déjà eu
beaucoup trop de sacrifices pour reculer